- [Marc Vines-Bright:] Adonis is destined for greatness.
He has something that most sighted people don’t have, and that’s vision.
He has a vision of his future.
He has a vision of what he wants in this world, and he’s not afraid to get it.
- [Adonis Watt:] Having sight or not having sight doesn’t really matter to me.
There’s no room for fear.
So technically I guess you could say I’m completely blind.
My mind, it’s almost like a TV that’s runnin’ 24/7. Images flash.
- Adonis, here I am.
- [Adonis:] It’s basically like I see ‘em, even though I really can’t.
It’s like an illusion in a way.
- [Veronica:] As an early child, Adonis was so jovial.
He was laughter all the time. We signed him up for football.
We bought his cleats that morning; we went swimming.
That was the day he lost his eyesight, so he never actually wore the cleats on the field.
- [Adonis:] Went underwater. I came up, and I couldn’t really see.
- [Veronica:] He has a very rare congenital glaucoma. One in 10,000 kids have this.
And it just so happened that I was there alone with him in the pool.
It could have happened at any time.
The next, like, I wanna say three or four years, I had 12, 12 eye surgeries. I hated them.
I would wake up, and it was like I didn’t have control of nothin’.
I would just woke up, like, just cryin’ for no reason.
You take for granted, like, the street or the grass or the sky, you know?
Just regular stuff like that outside.
- He says, “Mom, I gotta get ready to get back on the field.”
I wanted to say, “They’re not gonna accept you. They’re not gonna let you play.
And I said to him, “You’re gonna get hit on your blind side.”
And he says, “Mom, all my sides are blind. I know that.”
- [Adonis:] The only challenge I could, like, really remember
was gettin’ my parents to listen to me more.
They would hold me back.
Kinda had to find a way to convince ‘em to just let me go.
Other people probably do put limits on me. It’s just because they don’t know no better.
- [Sanaa Watt:] No, 2-1.
- First one doesn’t count.
- No, I made two.
- Thinkin’ about blind people, you think of, like,
Stevie Wonder and, like, Ray Charles and all them.
I’m playin’ football and doin’ basketball and runnin’ track
and doin’, all this, like, athletic stuff.
One more and I win.
To play basketball, I line up my phone with the net and then scoot it back
so it’s, like, under the backboard. Then I’ll play music.
♪♪♪
- Your net’s here. Nope. Jump.
- Hold this real quick.
And I’ll use the music to aim where I’m shooting at
If there was a miracle to happen, I’d probably end up playin’ basketball
cuz, let’s just be honest, I got the body of a basketball player,
and before I went blind, I was always hoopin’.
- [Veronica:] I tried to trick him. I’ve tried to delay him.
I tried to put him in different sports. He will not be blocked.
- Even in flag football, I was playin’, I was playin’ center.
So, I mean, I ain’t really get to, like, get the ball until probably I was, like, nine or 10.
- [Veronica:] It’s when he lost his eyesight he gained a whole new vision for his life.
He sees himself as, like, the strongest, the biggest, the fastest, the smartest, the most agile.
Like, he really believes he’s unstoppable.
- [Marc:] There we go. Big breath in, and exhale as you come back up.
Right side, there we go. And down.
- [Adonis:] To me, football has always been football, always gonna be football.
I wanna get faster, get stronger. I wanna get bigger.
There wasn’t even a thought of quitting.
- We’re workin’ on, really, strength, stability, uh, balance, or proprioception.
Later on down the line, it’s going to have to be building mass because he's gonna
take some hits because he’s not gonna be able to see everything comin’ at him.
- [Adonis:] Usin’ a cane’s kinda like an ongoing thing. You’re never, like, perfect at it,
but I guess you could say it took me four, maybe five years.
With Braille in general, learning how to read and write
probably took me, like, three years to be pretty good at it
Right here says, “I’m going to the NFL.”
As far as usin’ my phone, I was cool after, like, two weeks.
So I do this, slide it up. So nobody can hear what I’m textin’,
who I’m textin’, I speed up the speech.
Whatever I tap,  it says what I tap.
I basically remembered every letter in the keyboard,
so I just text like anybody else, and it sends ‘em out a text basically.
[Accelerated phone speech]
A lot, a lot of this stuff, as far as knowin’ where things is,
is just guessing games. And I don’t know if it’s, like, a feeling, but it's like
something goes off in my brain, like an alarm sayin’ I’ve been here before.
- [Scott Heideman:] When you hear as a football coach that you’re gonna
have a blind athlete come in and wanna play football, it was challenging.
The thought of, of somebody playing a position like running back
and not being able to see, it’s hard to wrap your mind around.
- [Adonis:] To be honest, I don’t think they completely,
completely believed that I could play running back.
- He doesn’t want anything given to him.
And when, you know, when we told the officials in his first game
where he scored a touchdown—he scored that touchdown based on the team
making a very sportsman-like action by letting him score.
But everybody around him knew that’s not what he wanted.
When we went into the next game, we didn’t really tell anybody.
And he scored two touchdowns. It was all earned.
- [Veronica:] Like, he’s not breaking records.
He’s setting records. Like, he’s the first. The first, the first, the first, the first, the first.
- [Adonis:] I remember havin’ to actually push through somebody and kinda,
like, almost dive in.
- [Player:] Get there!
- [Player:] That’s a touchdown! Let’s go!
- [Adonis:] It was pretty good knowin’ I could do it
when somebody was actually tryin’ to stop me.
- [Marc:] Imagine that in your head there was no other option but to run forward
and to run into that swarm. That’s where Adonis is. He has no choice.
- We talk about trust all the time, you know? Used to play quarterback.
I had to trust. Trust my receivers were gonna be in the right spot.
Trust those five guys up front, that they were gonna block their guy.
And that was with full vision. To trust those guys without vision,
knowin’ somebody’s tryin’ to hit you, I mean, it’s, it’s phenomenal.
- [Adonis:] I mean, my teammates is a big part cuz you can’t be by yourself and win.
You know, you need all 11 guys to do, to do their job.
To know that they got my back is pretty cool.
- One of the big things we stress here is trust.
Him following us around, putting his hand on our shoulder—
—all of us look at that, and we trust each other just a little bit more.
- In football, you can tend to, like, really get selfish and focus on yourself.
But when you have someone like Adonis there,
you recognize the importance of teamwork, and helping a fellow brother out.
I remember one practice, I was just messin’ around,
and I, like, tried—I closed my eyes and I was runnin’ through the plays,
and it was scary, really scary. So I just admire how fearless he is.
- He doesn’t let him being blind affect anything that he does.
Like, it’s just inspiring to see.
- [Scott:] The more I spent time with Adonis, the more his blindness disappeared
and the more I just saw him as Adonis the football player,
less as Adonis the blind football player.
- [Adonis:] What I like best is probably how hard you have to work,
how it’s just not given to you.
You gotta be somebody that’s gonna be, be able to go the extra mile.
- [Chanting] B-R-O-N-C-O-S, Broncos!
- [Jason Jewell:] You can’t go out on a pass,
and it’s tough to see where a blitzer is comin’ from,
so we gotta limit what we’re doing.
But last year he scored several touchdowns in short-yardage situations,
and I’m hopin’ we can do that again in 2019.
- [Cheering]
- [Adonis:] After high school, I’mma hopefully go to a D-I school on a scholarship.
After I produce there, hopefully I can get to the NFL
and get some rings and play for a long time.
- [Jason:] I’ve had thoughts of bein’ in a game-winning situation
on the 1-yard line. How awesome would it be to have Adonis in to score that touchdown?
- [Veronica:] And his faith actually has been the light that guides me through his darkness.
- [Announcer:] That’s the end of the game. Final score: Broncos 14, Bears 10.
Congratulations to head coach Tom Kohrs and the Brophy Broncos.
- [Coach:] But for next week, so—
- [Veronica:] We’ll be back Tuesday.
- Hope you can stay out with varsity.
Yeah, Tuesday morning is when—we’re not practicing Monday.
- [Veronica:] Perfect, yeah.
- All right.
- All right. Thanks, Coach.
- [Veronica:] All right. Thanks, Coach.
- Good season, Adonis.
- Thank you, Coach.
- [Adonis:] I mean, I think I would’ve ended up the way I am right now anyway, blind or not.
I mean, I guess you could say it gave, it gave me a little extra layer,
but, I mean, it didn’t, like, make too much of a difference
to who I was gonna end up bein’ anyway.
- [Newscaster:] This is Brophy’s No. 21, Adonis Watt.
We brought you this story last year—a blind freshman running back on the freshman team,
and tonight, making his varsity debut, scores from a yard out!
Yeah, that’s special. That’s big-time!
Congrats to Adonis Watt. Brophy stays unbeaten—
♪♪♪
- [Yelling and cheering]
- [Larry Fitzgerald:] How you guys doin’ today?
- [Yelling] Good!
- Good, good. Well, I appreciate you guys lettin’ me come in.
Anybody know where my man Adonis is?
- [Yelling] Yeah!
- Adonis, how you doin’, man?
- What’s up, bro?
- Good to see you, brother. You doin’ well?
- Yes, sir.
- Man, when I heard about you, man, like: “I gotta go over and meet my guy.
Man, I gotta, I gotta see this man.”
You’re much taller than I thought. You almost taller than me.
- So, you know, it’ll just be the two of us on the team are the only two guys
that have ever played ball with Fitz. Just me and you, Adonis.
- That’s crazy. You got a ring, though.
- Well, you’re right. I got—I’m one up on you there. I’m one up on Fitz there too!
- Yeah!
- [Larry:] We gonna walk out to the field now, OK? All right.
- You good if I just hold your shoulder?
- Yeah, yeah, it’s all good.
Bein’ blind since he was five years old, he’s never given up his passion for sports,
and that’s what’s inspiring to me. I’ve played football since I was his age,
and I couldn’t imagine not bein’ able to see.
But Adonis has beaten all the odds. Teammates are helpin’ him
be able to live his dream as well, and that’s what I love about sports.
- So this your 16 or 17?
- Sixteen. Yeah.
- So how, how you play so long?
- Uh, the Lord, the Lord’s been good to me.
Adonis, we’re here on the football field where you scored your touchdowns.
I wanna play a little quarterback, so I wanna reenact it.
I’m ready when you are.
- Yeah, let’s go.
- Let’s do it. All right, Adonis, they’re about to snap it.
- All right. Hey, line me up so I’m good.
- Yeah, you’re good. You’re good.
- All right. All right.
- Set, go!
- [Cheering]
- Let’s go, Don!
- Don Don!
- Attaboy!
- [Adonis:] Yes, sir.
- [Larry:] Good job, brother. Good job.
I really appreciate you allowin’ me to come out here
and, uh, practice a couple plays with you.
You’re a wonderful young man and a true inspiration
and thank you for lettin’ me come out here and be a part of your day.
- All right, man, thank you.
Thank you for comin’ out here and messin’ with me, dawg. I appreciate it.
- Absolutely, a pleasure. It’s a pleasure.
- [Offscreen:] One, two, three…
- [Together:] Bleacher Report!
- [Offscreen:] The revenge of the Birds, baby.
- [Laughing]
- [Offscreen:] Yeah, can we put this on Bleacher Report’s story?
- Tag me!
- I’m Larry Fitzgerald, and this is Bleacher Report.